oh it's out there disaster of biblical
Hollywood proportions it's coming and
the gridlock like something you've never
seen before the most traveled highway in
America is about to shut down for an
entire weekend traffic could be backed
up as much as 64 miles city officials
are really really serious stay the hell
away from the 405 so our felis
celebrities avoid the area la's darkest
day will be this man's finest hour are
you with reasontv we're online for us
not to have access to freeways it's like
the end of the world it really is
so was it really the end of the world
carmageddon is I was trying to think of
some good like were they like a lame
again or some but every whatever have
enough lima gettin is right the
apocalyptic event politicians and the
media predicted just didn't happen
carmageddon is a joke got am i giving
this BS people over exaggerated i mean
it seemed like the world was ending
that's not just over hyped by media and
maybe some interested people in fact
ellie's busiest streets and highways
were clearer than they may have ever
been people actually heeded the warnings
they stayed home change their plans so a
traffic disaster didn't happen but what
exactly did the project accomplish mayor
of Los Angeles Antonio Villaraigosa says
the billion-dollar constructionism
partment to add a ten mile high
occupancy vehicle lane or a carpool lane
it will help us build an HOV Lane
connect from Orange County all through
the San Fernando Valley it's part of a
bigger plan and a grander vision and
most importantly we'll do everything we
can to reduce congestion but Angelenos
we talked to were skeptical the project
would actually do that one thing we're
unhappy about is la doesn't seem to be
fighting the bullet in terms of a
traffic plan and a vehicle plan all
we're doing is adding traffic lanes the
toll road would have been much better
you know the type that you put it your
barcode on you want let's make it come
you're short be commercial by the time
this project finishes in two years
freeway will be just as busy well there
will be traffic if everybody continues
to be wedded to the single passenger
automobile we want to get them to
carpool we want to get them to use
public transit we wanted to get them out
of their car once in a while and this
was a great exercise to show them that
it's possible carpooling may be possible
but drivers aren't taking advantage of
the opportunity a recent foundation
study from 2003 says that the fraction
of commuters sharing the ride to work
declined in the 1990s from a nationwide
average of thirteen percent in 1992 11.4
percent in 2000
music keeps us the project ended 17
hours early but it's not over Angelenos
will have to relive the experience 11
months from now when the second half of
the project is finished so you can count
on one thing being in the sequel epic
gridlock more media hype avoid the area
more celebrity warnings and politicians
saying stuff like this don't get in your
car right now